[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition deux
présidentielles 360 voici les titres 1
la droite tente d'afficher son unité
faute de meeting commun françois fillon
et alain juppé étaient réunis ce matin
au siège de l'entreprise parisienne 10
heures pour une poignée de mains devant
les caméras
hier c'est nicolas sarkozy qui dans une
vidéo à renouveler ce soutien le
décryptage dans cette édition la
campagne vu du terrain suite de notre
série de reportages consacrés aux onze
candidats à la présidentielle nous avons
suivi cette semaine jacques cheminade à
75 ans il se présente pour la troisième
fois et attend toujours ce qu'il appelle
un effet catalyseur pour faire frémir
les sondages en sa faveur un statut pour
les assistants parlementaires après
laffaire pénélope fillon
ils s'étaient rassemblés à paris où une
meilleure reconnaissance de leur travail
ils ont été reçus par myriam el khomri
vous les entendrez dans un instant et je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez réagir à
cette émission sur twitter hashtag
présidentielle à 360
à quatre jours du premier tour un
nouveau soutien attendu pour françois
fillon son ancien rival à la primaire
alain juppé les deux hommes se sont
affichés côte à côte ce matin au siège
de l'entreprise de musique en ligne
deezer
alors qu'on attendait un meeting commun
une seule poignée de mains écoutaient ce
qu'on a dit nathalie kosciusko morizet
au micro de nelson gayton il ya un
message de rassemblement cette fin de
campagne a eu un message de nicolas
sarkozy hier aujourd'hui à cette visite
conjointe d'alain juppé françois fillon
bon c'est je pense que c'est un point
c'est important c'est bien en cette fin
de campagne un message de rassemblement
et mois à l'autre message que je veux
pas c'est surtout c'est un message de
mobilisation
on en a quatre qui sont dans un mouchoir
de poche c'est stressant on a
l'impression d'une certaine manière
qu'on joue l'avenir de la france au des
ébats ce stress il faut le transformer
en mobilisation et françois fillon a été
accueilli par quelques fonds d'écran qui
en disent long sur cette campagne avec
cette injonction rend l'argent vous
allez le voir sur cette photo prise ce
matin par simon barbarie on en vient à
présent à la campagne vu du terrain avec
le port
et du doyen de cette élection
présidentielle à 75 ans jacques
cheminade se présente pour la troisième
fois en déplacement ils multiplient les
stand-up pour faire entendre sa voix et
son programme
reportage à lyon de marib remo et jerome
browne il ne change pas de méthode par
rapport à sa dernière campagne
présidentielle de 2012
le stand-up dans la rue comme ici à lyon
un classique pour ce petit candidat aux
petits budgets et sociétés à contrôler
le capitalisme financiarisé vous voyez
la pme cheminade tourne à plein régime
en ce moment il ya à peu près dans cette
campagne un coeur de 50 personnes qui
travaillent avec moi
200 à 300 personnes dans le pays qui
sont en activité et constante affichage
de 6 200 tracts et puis quinze mille
personnes qui sont autour du fonds de
petites choses temps en temps on a
réussi ça et je pense que quand on a un
coeur on peut construire tout son coeur
et le cerveau un corps démonstration en
images avec un argumentaire qui séduit
donc le chômage en fait c'est un
prétexte
c'est juste que c'est quelque chose qui
est qui et direct qui découle
directement du fait qu'on contrôle pas
en fait ce prix ça qu'on parle ces
propositions globalement oui moi je suis
étudiante en lettres donc on la finance
je connais pas beaucoup
mais au moins c'est un discours
différent qui est proposé aux électeurs
parce que je considère que ces élections
elles sont elles sont croqués en fait on
se moque complètement de l'électorat
qu'on manipule l'opinion publique et une
voix qui sort un petit peu du lot c'est
important mais cela ne marche pas à tous
les coups
non
c'est moi qui te plaît mais je sais
qu'il va pas de chance il trouve que
pour une fois il ya la différence des
campagnes précédentes
on le perçoit autrement non plus
exclusivement comme le candidat loufoque
complotistes et lunaire car
contrairement aux idées reçues le
fondateur du parti solidarité et progrès
garde les pieds sur terre
non je suis pas du tout les connecteurs
vantagepoint ce qui me rend original
c'est être encore plus connectés que les
autres avec la réalité de la france et
les maires nous ont beaucoup aidés parce
qu'il ya beaucoup à apprendre d'eux les
gens qui ont des responsabilités
on apprend toujours quelque chose de oui
ce fut encore une fois une des surprises
de cette campagne présidentielle à 75
ans et pour la troisième fois depuis
1995 jacques cheminade à décrocher le
fameux sésame des 500 parrainages avec
un objectif combattre l'oligarchie
financière et en cette période d'équité
le doyen de cette campagne arrive à
mobiliser les médias mais pas forcément
les électeurs dans cette salle communale
de villefontaine à une trentaine de
kilomètres de lyon une douzaine de
curieux seulement a fait le déplacement
pour écouter ce singulier candidats près
de 47 millions d'électeurs sont
convoqués aux urnes pour le premier tour
dimanche afin de choisir entre onze
candidats le second tour est prévu le 7
mai le mode d'emploi de cette élection
avec stéphane à malien vous êtes
nombreux avoir reçu votre carte
électorale sachez qu'il n'est pas
obligatoire de la présenter le jour du
vote pour pouvoir voter il faut être
majeur et bien figurer sur les listes
électorales à défaut vous aviez jusqu'au
31 décembre dernier pour vous inscrire
dans la mairie de votre domicile ou de
votre résidence le jour du vote la pièce
d'identité elle est obligatoire
cela peut être une carte d'identité un
passeport un permis de conduire une
carte vitale avec photographie ou encore
un permis de chasser avec photographie
en cas d'impossibilité de vous rendre
aux urnes la procuration est possible
elle doit être réalisée le plus tôt
possible en ligne ou au tribunal
d'instance au commissariat de police ou
à la brigade de gendarmerie de votre
commune
le mandataire qui votera pour vous doit
être inscrit dans la même commune mais
pas nécessairement
le même bureau de vote le vote se fait à
bulletin secret et le passage par
l'isoloir est obligatoire nouveauté
cette année les bureaux de vote seront
ouverts de 8 heures à 19 heures
fermeture à 20 heures dans les grandes
villes
à côté et au lendemain de l'arrestation
de deux hommes suspectés de préparer un
attentat imminent la sécurité des
candidats renforcer comme celle des 60
mille bureaux de vote l'exécutif veut
rassurer c'est ce qu'a expliqué ce matin
stéphane le foll porte-parole du
gouvernement à l'issue du conseil des
ministres
on écoute cette menace terroriste est
toujours à un niveau élevé ce qui
nécessite plus que jamais la vigilance
de tous et elle doit nous engager à
rester mobilisé jusqu aux élections et
en particulier en tenant compte des
élections et de ce qu'elles peuvent
susciter avec des meetings et réunions
publiques et joue du vote donc nos mises
de l'intérieur rappelé curé cinquante
mille hommes qui seraient mobilisés pour
la sécurité
cinquante mille hommes tout en rappelant
aussi qui à peu près 60 7000 bureaux de
vote mais que l'ensemble des moyens sont
mis aujourd'hui en ordre
c'est une des conséquences de la sphère
pénélope fillon elle a permis de mettre
en lumière l'absence de statut des
assistants parlementaires
ils étaient rassemblés aujourd'hui à
paris avant d'être reçu par myriam el
khomri elle exige vous allez voir humeur
reconnaissance de leur travail jérôme
amené le temps presse pour les
assistants parlementaires car avec les
élections législatives en juin et les
sénatoriales en septembre
bon nombre d'entre eux vont perdre leur
emploi mobilisés depuis longtemps sur le
sujet d'un véritable statut d'assistant
il espère que le gouvernement enclenche
des avancées sur ce dossier ses devoirs
un statut de la profession a motivé une
convention collective serait l'idéal
et après tout ce qu'ils nous aient droit
normalement en tant que salarié comité
d'hygiène et de sécurité comité
d'entreprise pour renforcer dialogue
social autour de notre profession reçus
par la ministre myriam el khomri
l'intersyndicale est resté plus d'une
heure dans son bureau
et c'est sur la question des
licenciements en fin de mandat de leurs
parlementaires que la délégation a
obtenu des nouvelles rassurantes
notamment de la part de la direction
générale du travail
la dgt il n'y a pas d'impossibilité de
faire des licenciements pour motif
économique
au contraire puisque selon
l'interprétation de la dgt
on l'a remis nos analyses et compris par
écrit ça représentait même moins de
risque juridique de procéder par motif
économique
concrètement cela devrait permettre des
licenciements pour motif économique
ouvrant droit au chômage à hauteur de 75
% du salaire contre 53% pour motif
personnel la direction générale du
travail doit désormais sous 10 jours
envoyer ses recommandations aux deux
présidents des assemblées
claude bartolone et gérard larcher qui
pourront transmettre cet avis aux
parlementaires qui restent les
employeurs individuels des assistants et
donc responsable de la rupture des
contrats et dans le reste de l'actualité
au sénat un rapport de la délégation
collectivités territoriales sur les
nouvelles technologies au service de la
modernisation des territoires plusieurs
préconisations étaient présentés dont
une meilleure couverture numérique du
territoire
les explications de jacques mézard au
micro de elodie grégoire
il est indispensable d'avoir une
politique sur numériques qui soient
beaucoup plus volontariste et que si les
opérateurs font des choix qui ne sont
pas conformes à l'intérêt national
l'état prenne des décisions nécessaires
en leur laissant un délai et ensuite
pour intervenir quant au financement
bien sûr ce sont des choix mais ce sont
des choix d'investissement est
aujourd'hui la priorité doit être donnée
je dirai à la réduction des dépenses de
fonctionnement bien évidemment pour
privilégier l'investissement et ça c'est
un investissement de qualité
place à présent à l'analyse et au
décryptage des enjeux de ce premier tour
avec mes invités dans notre débat
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir olivier
rouquan bonsoir politologue au centre
d'études et de recherches en sciences
administratives et politiques merci
d'être avec nous et stéphane zumsteeg
bonsoir vous êtes juin directeur du
département politique opinion chez ipsos
merci à tous les deux premières
questions pour vous stéphane steg
on le voit ce pour la première fois
cette année on risque peut-être à 20h
dimanche ne pas avoir les deux noms qui
vont s'afficher sur nos écrans de
télévision
il y aura peut-être un écran partagé en
quatre temps les écarts se resserrent
dans cette dernière ligne droite
d'autant il faut le préciser il ya cette
particularité les bureaux de vote ne
vont pas fermer leurs portes à 18h mai à
19h 20h dans les grandes villes
qu'est ce que ça change comment
allez-vous travailler pour nous ça
change beaucoup de choses
évidemment nous disposerons d'une heure
de moins que précédemment lors des cdd
des scrutins précédents pour estimer les
résultats être en mesure de livrer de
l'est le nom des deux qualifiés à 20
heures mais je n'aurai pas être notre
objectif reste malgré tout d'être en
mesure de faire nous notre objectif
c'est de donner l'ordre d'arrivée des
quatre premiers et surtout évidemment
parce que c'est ce qui intéressera le
plus les téléspectateurs et les
commentateurs politiques les deux
qualifiés pour le second tour
et pourtant les biarrots quand c'est
vrai qu'on s'attend un match à quatre
très serrée dans un mouchoir de poche
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut avoir
quand même une surprise avec un candidat
qui est même en tête largement à
dimanche soir on peut avoir comme vous
dites des surprises puisque la proche en
termes de sondages c'est quand même une
approche en termes de probabilité c'est
sont des probabilités donc on a vu
surgir assez rapidement lors des
primaires un sursaut en faveur d'un
candidat
donc pourquoi ne pas imaginer que ce
soit possible
ce qui est intéressant dans la sphère du
match à 4 telle qu'elle est installée
tel qu'il est installé pardon depuis
quelques temps c'est que cela augmente
l'intérêt est donc peut-être diminue
l'abstention et qu'il y aura un surcroît
de mobilisation qui n'était pas anticipé
il ya quelques semaines dans tout ceci
rajoute finalement à j'allais dire une
certaine au suspense à une certaine
incertitude ceci dit les probabilités
qui qui existe dans ce match à quatre
bons elles sont elles sont assez floues
puisque à quelques pourcentages près un
candidat peut dépasser enfin peut surgir
comme vous dites et et se retrouvait
devant alors qu'ils étaient les données
2d 3e et ali a semble-t-il une
incertitude notamment sur la
mobilisation de l'électorat de la droite
classique parce que là françois fillon
est en dessous de ce que fait la droite
classique normalement donc là c'est un
des points un second point me
semble-t-il c'est l'électorat qui se
portera une fille née sur marine le pen
parce que on dit que certains certains
électeurs dans les zones rurales
reculées
c'est aussi ce qui fait la spécificité
de cette campagne par rapport aux autres
c'est que les mouvements d'opinion sais
pas qui sont importants c'est que
parfois ils sont bruce qui sont violents
on l'a vu avec la bombe la progression
spectaculaire de jean-luc mélenchon
on le voit aussi aujourd'hui avec
l'érosion qui reste malgré tout assez
limité des deux favoris en tout cas des
deux candidats que l'on met
systématiquement en tête dans les
intentions de vote à marine le pen
emmanuel macron ils ont subi une petite
érosion
mais on voit bien qu'il ya des des
électeurs qui pouvait nous dire voter
pour marine le pen un moment donné de la
campagne et qui a un autre moment
affichent leur préférence pour jean luc
mélenchon puis passe à emmanuel macron à
une volatilité entre des candidats qui
pourtant n'ont rien à voir
idéologiquement ou en termes de
personnalité un élément nouveau qui a
surgi hier sa cette menace terroriste
olivier rouquan est-ce que vous pensez
que ça peut jouer à la fois dans le
choix des électeurs mais aussi peut-être
sur la mobilisation la participation des
gens parce qu'être inquiet dimanche et
hésité à se rendre au guichet on peut
tout imaginer mais il est dit vraiment
très difficile d'imaginer l'impact que
pourrait avoir ce risque
le fait qui ressurgissent dans le débat
on avait vu en 2012 avec la ferme et
racks avait cristallisé un peu sur la
fin également le dans tous les cas la
tension et puis en 2002 on se souvient
de la du thème de la sécurité et d'un
événement d'un fait divers qui à la fin
était venu aussi qui avait eu un
traitement dans la formation mais il est
très difficile de mesurer l'impact que
ça sur le vote et sur le comportement
électoral
il ya cette grande volatilité par
exemple on a parlé de deux cas
précédemment fillon et le pen avec des
incertitudes mais mélenchon aussi parce
qu'il a une part de deux votes jeunes
très élevé sa troisième place dans deux
sondages
c'est un sondage ifop fiducial
mais chez nous aussi il est très
légèrement très légèrement distancé par
françois fillon ii malgré tout ils
occupent tous les deux les 3e et 4e
places à peu près au même niveau dans la
zone selon des instituts des 19 ou des
20% tout tout peut arriver dans notre
dernière livraison de ce midi dans le
monde évidemment
les quatre candidats tiennent en quatre
points il tenait en trois points la
semaine dernière dans une autre enquête
tout peut-être effectivement arriver
mais petit à petit malgré tout on
annonce une abstention record on a
annoncé à juste titre une volatilité
très importante nous avons mesuré ces
deux éléments mais on se rend compte
qu'au fur et à mesure qu'on se rapproche
de dimanche prochain
il ya plus en plus de français qui nous
déclarent être certains d'aller voter
7dans l'enquète d'aujourd'hui sont 72%
c'était bien moins il ya encore une
semaine où il ya deux semaines on voit
bien que les candidats qui cherchent à
mobiliser depuis le week end pascal bien
réussissent quand même un petit peu a
rameuté et des lecteurs
est-ce que c'est l'émergence aussi de
petits candidats qu'on a pu bien parti
si je ne suis pas sûr parce que
manifestement dans les intentions de
vote
il ne se distingue pas la différence
d'ailleurs de ce qui s'était produit par
exemple en 2002 où le surgissement
notamment d'olivier besancenot des
petits candidats avait modifié la donne
et fait perdre des points aux ténors
entre guillemets et là on voit que
notamment jean luc mélenchon ne pâtit
pas trop de l'émergence de philippe
poutou par exemple donc nathalie arthaud
donc il y a
cette fois ci les petits candidats vont
ils sont là ils sont dans le
symboliquement là mais pour l'instant
leur porte et on verra dans le vote mais
dans les intentions n'est pas mais pas
très forte
idem pour les candidats eurosceptiques
françois asselineau nicolas dupont
aignan ils ne vont pas et bien sur le
terrain électoral de marine le pen ça ne
change pas la donne non ça change pas
beaucoup la donne d'ailleurs si l'on
prend le cas particulier de nicolas
dupont aignan c'est pas facile pour lui
parce que pour faire basculer un
électeur souhait de françois fillon vers
nicolas dupont aignan soit de
l'abstention vers nicolas dupont aignan
alors qu'il a un électorat de droite un
de droite parfois un peu dur il ne peut
faire basculer que des gens qui décident
qu'ils ne veulent pas de françois fillon
comme président la république et il est
très parle beaucoup du vote utile à
gauche ou du vote utile macron mélenchon
mais nicolas dupont aignan le mais aussi
des victimes du vote utile
à droite on parlait de françois fillon
qui a reçu aujourd'hui le soutien tant
attendu d'alain juppé alors ça n'a pas
pris la forme d'un meeting commun avec
le candidat de la droite à la
présidentielle mais cette image d'unité
de façade de la droite on a vu françois
fillon alain juppé visiter l'entreprise
de musique en ligne deezer
comment analysez vous cette image on
vire au camp comme vous dites d' unité
de façade il faut bien quand même à
quelques jours du premier tour indiqué
que ce rassemblement qui évoqué si
souvent et factuelle donc il ya cette
image mais je ne dirais pas que c'est
une image d'epinal mais enfin c'est
quand même une image qui a été fabriqué
sur le mode du service minimum j'allais
presque dire mais bon c'est toujours un
indice envoyé un électorat qui en
attente parce qu'on l'a dit il ya une
sous représentation pour l'instant
derrière ses intentions de vote de
françois saillant de ce que pèse la
droite classique ne serait-ce qu'à
prendre les derniers
scrutin intermédiaire les élections
locales on a bien vu quand même là que
la droite classique
obtenez des résultats tout à fait
honorables sont aujourd'hui soutien de
nicolas sarkozy hier et avec cette
question se voit de cachet est ce qu il
existait vraiment l'un des grands débats
de cette campagne mais nous ne croyons
pas véritablement l'existence d'un vote
cachée de votre cash et d'expression
elle date de l'émergence du front
national l époque où les gens dans les
enquêtes d'opinion même donc dans la
réalité du scrutin avaient du mal à
reconnaître qu'il votait pour les
candidats frontistes ou pour jean marie
le pen se rend compte que ces choses là
n'existe plus vraiment puisque la
sous-évaluation du front national n'est
plus véritablement un problème on sait
gérer ce genre de ce genre de niveau ce
genre ce genre de mesures pour françois
fillon
ça me paraît compliqué de parler de
votre cash est traditionnellement les
gens de droite n'éprouve pas de honte à
l'égard du vote pour un candidat de
droite
l'épisode parce que nous n'y croyons pas
après ce qui peut effectivement se
produire dans les derniers jours voire
dans les derniers heurts dans les
dernières heures avant le vote est une
sorte de vote retardé quelque part une
partie de cet électorat de droite qui a
quitté françois fillon a demandé soit
pour emmanuel macron soit pour la soie
pour l'abstention au tout dernier moment
se disant ce n'est pas possible cette
élection à l'été pour la droite elle
était pour nous nous étions 106 était
censé être notre tour et ce n'est pas
possible finalement que nous ayons un
candidat de centre de centre gauche peu
importe quoi comme on voit emmanuel
macron est qu'au tout dernier moment il
ya une part significative de ses de ses
anciens fillonniste qui redeviennent
fillonniste le jour du vote c'est pour
ça que c'est aussi une des incertitudes
de ce premier tour mais ce serait plus
moi je pense avoir retardé en revanche
sur sont très difficiles à paris non ça
semble l'écart est trop important
semble-t-il et cette fois ci mais il
peut y avoir un petit un peu à l'image
d'ailleurs de mai toutes proportions
gardées de ce qui pourrait se passer en
faveur de françois fillon dans votre
légitimiste les dire c'est qu'au dernier
moment des électeurs chelsea dont on met
lass qui se joue c'est finalement la
survie de la maison donc il pourrait y
avoir un petit surcroît mais l'écart est
trop important notamment vis-à-vis de
jean-luc mélenchon pour que l'espérer
semble-t-il cette fois ci être au second
tour ce serait vraiment là pour le coup
une énorme surprise encore descendre
dans les intentions rien est exclue si
la dynamique en faveur de jean-luc
mélenchon se poursuit c'est aussi une
des possibilités des éventualités
elle se fera essentiellement au
détriment de jean luc mélenchon dans les
mélenchon il a pris presque 10 points en
quelques semaines il l'est la quasi
totalité de ses gains il les a obtenues
auprès de benoît hamon voilà mais de
toute façon le fait que benoît hamon ce
qui est quasiment une certitude
maintenant soit derrière jean-luc
mélenchon quel que soit leur niveau
respectif et déjà une catastrophe pour
le parti socialiste jean luc mélenchon
juste un point d' alerte ou de risques
c'est l'importance du vote des jeunes en
sa faveur ont aussi qu il ya là un
décalage entre l'intention de vote et
l'acte de vote auprès des 18-24 ans
notamment ils sont moins nombreux à
aller voter ce qui pourrait donner un
résultat moins important que celui qui
est annoncé mais c'est encore une fois
lorsqu on raisonne en termes de
probabilité on a 30 secondes pour
conclure ce débat ont parlé d' emmanuel
macron il continue à truster les
intentions de vote à les sondages a
conservé sa première place
cette première place ou alors il est au
coude à coude avec marine le pen mais il
ya toujours un écart de 3 2 4 points
selon les enquêtes avec françois fillon
et avec jean luc mélenchon ce n'est pas
rien et trois ou quatre points il ne
reste plus que quelques jours
finalement donc et d'autre part il ya un
autre élément c'est que très longtemps
tout au long de la campagne nous avons
insisté nous comme les autres sur le
fait que l'électorat en faveur de fillon
et de marine le pen était plus certains
plus convaincus c'est vrai que
l'électorat de maquereaux n'était plus
fragiles mais là encore notables on le
voit depuis ce week-end depuis sa
prestation réussie à bercy notamment
on voit bien que des électeurs qui
affichent une préférence pour emmanuel
macron sent de plus en plus sûrs de leur
choix et considère qu'ils ne changeront
plus d'avis
eh bien merci tout de suite on continue
de décrypter la présidentielle avec à la
rubrique facteurs année
[Musique]
et entre nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
bonsoir tam alors avec on va continuer à
démêler le vrai du faux dans cette
campagne présidentielle ce soir on
s'intéresse à une proposition de nicolas
dupont aignan il conseille concerne le
terrorisme il était d'ailleurs notre
invité hier on écoute j'ai été moquée ok
ce que j'ai entendu
quand j'ai demandé qu'on isole les
djihadistes dangereux j'ai été moquée
vous avez même changer cette proposition
vous aviez quid du yen est désormais
parce que j'ai les îles kerguelen oui
parce que j'ai blessé les guyanais et
j'aime pas blesser des ultramarins qui
n'ont rien demandé et j'ai reconnu mon
tort et comme en plus j'ai vu que halo
kerguelen y avait des baraquements tout
à fait possible pour accueillir les
djihadistes retour au bagne donc pour
les djihadistes mais cette fois
direction les îles kerguelen vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus sur saisine eh
bien ces îles kerguelen c'est un
archipel perdu au coeur de l'océan
indien à 12000 kilomètres de la france
et qui appartient aux terres australes
et antarctiques françaises
les îles kerguelen autrefois elle était
surnommée les îles de la désolation
et pour cause aujourd'hui encore elle ne
compte aucun habitant permanent
alors vous le voyez sur ces images les
îles kerguelen c'est beau c'est désert
et désertique il ya plus de manchots
royaux que d'humains là bas et en termes
d'infrastructures et bien il ya des
baraquements désinfecter investissent de
l'activité d'élevage du saumon dans les
années 80 notamment et des
infrastructures scientifiques qui marche
encore le seul endroit habité c'est
d'ailleurs la base de port aux français
qui abrite aujourd'hui une communauté
oscille entre 50 et 100 personnes pour
l'essentiel des scientifiques des
militaires et des ouvriers
on voit donc mal comment pour un stand
présente sur place effectivement ça
paraît très difficile ça a fait crac il
y est d'ailleurs sur place du personnel
administratif pénitentiaire des
policiers qui vivrait là alors qu'il
n'ya aucune ressource il faudrait donc
tout un cheminot pareil pour construire
cette prison ce ban il faudra envoyer
tout le matériel par bateau il n'ya même
pas là bas de piste d'atterrissage bref
c'est une opération qui coûteraient
beaucoup beaucoup trop cher ajoutez à
cela que les seules personnes mises en
place ce sont des scientifiques des
scientifiques qui ne rêve pas d'avoir
pour unique voisins à des hadjis
dist oui j'en parlais tout à l'heure il
ya une communauté scientifique sur place
qui travaillent dans des observatoires
du cnes le centre national d'études
spatiales et aussi du cea le centre
d'études atomiques
c'est un endroit très approprié pour
étudier l'espace notamment parce qu'il
n'y a pas là bas de pollution visuelle
qui empêche l'observation du ciel
les scientifiques étudient aussi
notamment la sismologie la chimie
atmosphérique ou bien encore la
météorologie et puis il faut encore
ajouter et que eh bien ces îles
kerguelen
elles appartiennent à la réserve
naturelle nationale des terres australes
l'une des plus grandes aires marines
protégées sur la planète qui existe
d'ailleurs depuis plus de dix ans et qui
a été étendue à six cents 600 mille
kilomètres carrés par la dernière loi
sur la biodiversité
je sais vous êtes amusé thème en
préparant cette chronique il ya un
symbole qui vous a fait rire
et oui les îles kerguelen c'est aussi
une sorte de pavillon de complaisance
c'est à dire un pavillon bis qui est
utilisée par certains bateaux pour son
caractère peu contraignant en matière de
fiscalité de sécurité du navire ou
encore du droit du travail en laisse que
nicolas dupont aignan 1 c'est à dire
monsieur un moralisation monsieur grand
ménage voudrait qui a envoyé des
djihadistes 1 pour punir cette espèce de
paradis fiscal des bateaux on se demande
alors en résumé dans la proposition de
nicolas dupont aignan d'envoyer les
djihadistes sur les îles kerguelen
eh bien elle n'est pas seulement
saugrenue elle est aussi irréaliste pour
des raisons de coût et d'infrastructures
sans compter que les îles kerguelen ne
sont pas un simple petit confetti de la
république c'est un lieu de recherche de
pointe et une réserve naturelle
essentiel au niveau planétaire
merci beaucoup uttam on se retrouve
demain pour un nouveau facteur king
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous d'avoir suivi à suivre l'épreuve de
vérité spécial présidentiel trois
invités ce soir christine ne pouvons pas
un soutien de philippe poutou bruno
retailleau de l'équipe de campagne de
françois fillon
et enfin philipp metzger pour jean
lassalle très bonne soirée à tous et à
demain 18
[Musique]
m